there is something we desperately need
that we cannot stop doing it is
breathing do you want to try why we
don't stop breathing together for let's
say even 10 seconds that ok let's do it
get ready okay now
difficult isn't it well this is an
incredible number that will again take
your breath away
7 7 what 7 million premature deaths a
year caused by exposure to the bad
quality of the air we breathe imagine
it's like more than the entire
population of my dear Madrid will be
wipe out in one year you may ask is this
information being disclosed has this
information being the published size
distributed well yes we have at the
moment
more than 70,000 scientific papers
examine the relationship between air
pollution and our health in the global
media has been regularly covering this
issue in fact in a relatively short
period of time we have come to know that
air pollution is having a negative
impact in almost all our major organs
let's start by the lungs when we think
about our pollution we always think
about the lungs in fact every time we
take a breath we are inhaling toxic
pollutants and our poor pinky and lovely
lungs are suffering all of that over the
last 10 years we have put together a lot
of knowledge about what's happened to
that but let me tell you first what is
air pollution ok air pollution is a very
complex mixture of leti solid particles
liquid droplets and gaseous chemicals
imagine all of this mixture that my come
from sources like household fuel burning
or industry or traffic or many other
indoor and outdoor sources and of course
different sources of pollution will make
different mix
of pollutants the point is that all of
these toxics they can be combined in
different ways let's take for instance
the particulate matter the PM it can be
a mixture that will include look at the
cocktail here
soil and rod dust sea salt toxic metals
this cell smoke nitrates and sulfates
and all of this toxic poison this
delicious cocktail is going through our
lungs every day and we are constantly
exposed to this air pollution because we
can not stop breathing I mean we can do
it for 10 seconds much more no more than
that we cannot stop breathing and in
addition we need every day around
approximately 10,000 liters of air so we
said that we have 7 million deaths
caused by air pollution every year are
we panicking are we keeping calm are we
declaring a national disaster a global
emergency well no and in fact I'm asking
myself this question every day what is
happening but here is something that
maybe will force us to react more
quickly air pollution is not just
affecting our lungs it's affecting as
well our brain this is our brain
beautiful we all have it we all need it
hopefully we all use it some more than
others and in the last 10 years of
history there research about the
relationship between air pollution and
our brain cells has been increased
dramatically so maybe now our brain is
going up in smoke but let me tell you
what the evidence what we know so far
about air pollution in our brain first
there is an emerging body of evidence
regarding the potential harmful effects
of air pollutants into our central
nervous system but let's go back to the
toxic particles remember we left them at
the lungs enjoy in life polluting
everything but now the smallest of them
they can cross into the bloodstream and
from the bloodstream pump by the heart
they can reach the whole body
threatening every organ including the
brain we used to say that their
pollution has no borders and is true as
well within our bodies because our
pollutants will cross the placental
barrier and reach the fetes in altering
the cerebral cortex of our children even
before they take the first breath second
several studies have suggested that both
prenatal in early childhood long term
exposure to air pollution will have a
negative influence on neural development
will have lower cognitive test outcomes
and there will be an influence as well a
negative influence in some behavioral
disorders like autism and attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder in
addition to that some evidence found
that exposing our children and young
adults brains for a long time to
particulate matter will be causing some
reactions like a brain in flama
inflammation altering the immune
response in as well leading to influence
of more protein plugs that are
accumulating and those can increase the
risk for diseases like Alzheimer
in Parkinson ironic isn't it we are
investing on our children's future we
are sending them to school every day to
span their minds the Society's investing
in their education
yet the air they breathe while waiting
for for the school bus is influencing
negatively there the development of
their brain let's go to the third what
about adult
according to recent scientific evidence
long-term exposure to particulate matter
will cause a cognitive decline on a
study participants as their age and not
only that if you suppose them to long
term very fine particulate matter their
brain will age more rapidly and they
will have higher odds of having small
silent strokes the last one and I will
not give you more evidence because there
is none of them some epidemiological
studies in animal models have suggested
that there might be an increased risk of
dementia with a sustained exposure to
air pollutants so almost everybody is
false to our pollution whether you live
in a rural area or an urban area whether
you live on a high-income country or a
low-income country everybody's brains
including yours are at risk as a medical
doctor I have been dedicating the last
more than twenty years now of my
professional life to raise awareness
about public health issues public health
risks and the World Health Organization
and I know that the knowledge is there
in the solutions as well sure some
places are more polluted than others but
this is a global issue and no individual
no City no group no country nor region
will be able to solve it alone we need
very strong commitments and very strong
action by everyone civil society private
sector even individuals we all have a
role to
yes we need to influence the way we
consume the way we commute the way we
use our energy and the good thing is
that all of those solutions are
available the question is if we postpone
action by one day there might be
thousands of lives that we will lose but
if we postpone it by one year we might
be losing again seven Millions
so every policymaker every politician
needs to be aware of the consequences of
human health or postponing their
decisions in fact this is not the first
time in history that we are confronted
to their risks of this invisible killer
this was London in 1952 and as was done
in London in the 50s and the 60s
governments in cities they need to take
all team action to stop the terrible
impact of air pollution every politician
must know that delaying what they call
the tough actions like reducing traffic
in cities or investing on public
transport and engaging on promoting
cycling in cities investing on renewable
energy promoting cleaner energy for
cooking cooling in transportation and
heating our solutions that are very
smart because in fact they reduce
emissions they improve air quality in
line with double standards which are the
standards that will protect ourselves so
in fact all politicians that we need
this very strong political commitment in
political will but all of them are now
those who fail to postpone action they
have been requested even to defend their
position
in court and from now on it no
politician will be able to say I didn't
know so the question here is how many
lives loss of quality of life in losing
our brain power
are we ready to accept if the answer is
none I will request you that while our
brain is still functioning while we are
still intelligent please exercise your
right put pressure on your politicians
and make sure that they take action to
stop the sources of air pollution this
is the first thing we need to do to
protect yourself and to protect our
beautiful brain thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]